>>THCOVILL
M ANTHAT'S MY L E COMING
AE MIDS
THEY'RE AR HOUGH MOSTD SK
OF BECOMING SEVERELY.
'S A TOUGH TIME  BE YOUNAND ON
ANAUNCH.IN DEPRE A
THIM LEARNING.S YOUTRA
AIN W YORK CITY AND IN D.C. WH
ENE REQUIREDODUCE GAES.
BUT THIS WEEK INE
THOL DISICUNTRY, THE TEACHERS' I
VOTED EFO SHP FOR
IN-PN ENDING SCHOO
ALTOGETHER.Y, T SECONDACK FROM
HIGHEST HEL
DIST HE THAN00
STTHISTO%
TO A SHOULDNRING EVEIN
THOUSAND OAROUND THE CDEREN LEA
CINCTICLUDING ATLANT
WHATAP END A SWITCD E
$130WEUPPOSE
EARMARKER VEIL SROOMS MORE FO. ?
ASNEW YORK TIMES" HEAD
ITAY UP. T YEA AMERICANSHAVE ACO
CHILDREN LES
HARM TO ADULTS
INCLUDING TO SICBYS AUTHORD TO
AN STUDENTS AS SEARCH GRALLS WEO
STUDEOOLSY CADEMY OF HO, H PER,
I'T STUDENTS SSDYNAMICS.
WHAT YE , IT THENT
FORGOFATIONSAND THERE'S T IS CAE
TH THAADT
CIRCUMSTANCTHE ONES THAT HAVED.
RIOOL BUAFTERNN SPORTS ARE NR
FIRST  B
LOSI T NUANC NT CAN IDVIINONLIT
YEARS I  I'M DIFNT
PERSON
RE STILTEDD YES,'S A GOOTHING B
THEY'RE DEPRIVED OON-THEOBFORTS
NTN THRADERI
WITHRA
LAW I LEARMOM WATCHING
RS TRYHAN THREE
INAPOPABITE NOFORMEDMEBODY NEEDA
COMMUNICATTHERIOR.AND SOMETIMESP
JOB DONETHESE ELEMENTARY
CHICAGO WHO MISSEDEK
OOL,IGND AVE MISSED
MIUP
ALK PRCE
AN IEMPLATING A RESPONSE T NOT T
PRIORITIZED. NOW ICA
RODRIGUEZ, FAUFOUNDER D
IOL
PAREUNNIU
YOU'R
O THENE PAG
REACT  I THI SD  ALL 5
BEAUTIFULLY, M
ANKLY,LY, WHATE LOOKING ATIGHTEH
BEEN IN CHR THE PAST 20
BACK I OF 2020 WHEREE TALKING TG
HE NEE
CONTINGENCY
ALL RIGHT.D % OFES D N NATIONAG
ATEN EARNSES AND UNFOLR LIVING
ROOMS IS NUMBER  HOW MUCH LOHIC,
EYEEE DIFFEREN
RESPI E
NEITHER OF THEM ISTI
ATU SEE?
>> PROBLEM IS OFHIOM THEFEDERAL
SITUATION, COVID-19 MITIGAKIG,
KI WE HA
TECHNOLOGYTHE WO SCENARIC
OCCURRED WE E PREPARETHEY'
ESSENTIAST HAVE.
INTOA GENERATION
E DON'T HOS
LINE.T MAY BE A
SIMPLIFICATION, T STATES
ENRERD
HEALTH.NTA
SOME IN TWASI LOOK AD E WAY THEC
>> WELL, TMICH WT BEING TOLD IG
QUALIFIED. RFOE STAYIN
GO BACTOWE
OU
G TO KEEMSEN BEC YE EE
RS Y'RE ING TO
DOWNVE
MORNING A WINTER BO E WHS COANE.
SHSCS,F NOAT WBREAK. WE'RE GOINO
KNG BACK TO  B, WITH A COVID RI
YOU' GO ON SCHOOORNING
T MMENSEIT'S AS IF WE HAD NOA AN
AND THATO HA
I'ANDEMIOLT, FHAD A PRETTY
>> MINE ARE OLDER THANOUF THEMS
MARRIED AND MO OWN
ATONLY T
STILL IN SCHOOL,UT
TH OSHOULDED BY W.
PROCESS BECAUSHE
ARTICULATED.
YOU GEWORD
GO
>> IE GOT TO TELL YOU,CH
CANNOT WK T S GRAS C
THEYE KINDERGARTEN KIDS
D COLLEG.GIANMI
SEAR F LOGIN G THETO
L SHOW UWORKIL SURURE
HETIT ONS BE THEON S A
SOCIY YSTH AMERICAN
THAT'S NOT HOW OURILIES WORK
AN NEETOSE
OUR FALI A RIG
E INUNFOATEM
BILLION IN FUNDING WISVE $13